[Music]
as the year draws to an
end i think it's time to start looking
at the year as a whole this year has
been an eventful one for anime and i
feel like now is a good time to start
going over what i think are the top 10
best new anime of the year i know that
the year was chock full of sequels and a
lot of which concluded
years of journey for some shows so i've
intentionally excluded those
and i'm talking about some of my
favorite ones from this year so without
further ado the top 10 best new anime of
2020 everyone
[Music]
we'll start things off with moriarty the
patriot honestly speaking i didn't have
high
hopes for this one that's not to be
taken in a negative light but as someone
who's seen quite a lot of sherlock
holmes anime it just doesn't feel too
special anymore while none of them ended
up being bad and it takes an
extraordinary amount of mishap to spend
five minutes ranting about a show online
they were
just out there what could a perspective
change to star the villain do
well a lot apparently midway through the
season moriarty the patriot has shot up
to be one of my favorites this season it
may not be part of the big hype train
that everyone's riding nor is it
something that i'd watched a few
goosebumps
and that sort of thing but the show's
brimming with content that makes you
think i'm not going to pretend that this
is some super complex big brain anime
that would make you question the meaning
of existence
but its themes make a lot of sense
especially given modern day context i
really like how it toys with the ideas
of justice while putting us in the
proper atmosphere for such thoughts
you've gotta thank the art and voice
acting departments for that
the show is still airing but you should
definitely check it out it gives you
food for thought and shows you what a
good villain protagonist looks like
next we go full throttle with god of
high school the much awaited
webtoon adaptation has been one of the
highlights of the summer 2020 season i'm
not surprised that jin mori's quest to
become the greatest fighter in korea
made its mark on the anime community
it didn't matter that it was in a season
with tons of grand finales and big
sequels
if there's anything to remember summer
2020 by in terms of just pure hype a lot
of anime fans will tell you it's
probably
god of high school nevertheless the
show's not without its flaws as we've
seen
so far with the three korean webtoon
adaptations
tower of god and noblesse being the
other two the adaptation styles have
been um
a bit hit or miss god of high school in
particular got some flack for cutting
out some key character development parts
from the webtoon while i think that the
criticism that is nothing but fight
after fight a bit overblown i have to
agree to a certain extent
still if you love fights and fights as
well as stunning animation and visuals
god of high school could be just the
show for you
[Music]
for the rom-com fans you'll probably
remember summer 2020 not for god of high
school but
for rent a girlfriend i haven't seen the
fake girlfriend storyline in a while so
i don't blame anyone for thinking of
rent a girlfriend as the second coming
of nisakoi unfortunately renter
girlfriend never quite hit the mark as
the series that is supposedly a
spiritual successor to
a lot of that falls onto our protagonist
now i don't know if it's just me
but it does seem that he's by far the
most hated protagonist in a series with
harem elements this season
now sharing a season with kirito that's
saying something
actually we can extend that past the
season and make it to the year
and you can throw mommy in there while
you're at it now that might sound a bit
harsh but i did sincerely enjoy rent a
girlfriend in general the characters may
be controversial but i enjoyed the
comedy bits and i don't think anyone's
denying that the girls are pretty good
and as they say
in a show like this it's not the harem
protagonist that does the heavy lifting
but the girls if they sell the show
sells and it apparently did well enough
to get a second season coming our way
[Music]
let's make it three in a row now for
summer 22 with
decadence so if god of high school is
the mainstream shonen boys pick of the
season
well rent a girlfriend is what rom-com
fans remember it by i think that it
would be fair to give decadence the
crown for under-appreciated hit of the
season
what many people first brushed off for
some sort of sci-fi attack on titan
quickly found its footing and surged in
popularity midway through the season
it's the season's example of not judging
a book by its cover as much of the
content that made it capture the hearts
of so many fans came out midway through
its run
the plot may have seemed simple but
decadence does have quite a lot of
philosophical concepts that get explored
i'm positive that i'm not the only one
who thought that the show ended up
looking like a completely different one
that first impressions might have given
us even at two episodes in
before i forget the show did have a
controversial ending but i feel like it
wrapped things up pretty nicely for an
anime original so if you're looking for
a short one
call show to binge over a weekend and
you're up for something that reminds you
of attack on titan or guru lagan
make sure to give decadence a world
speaking of endings gleibnir has a
[ __ ] of an ending for its anime
but that doesn't pull it down so hard
for me not to feature as one of the top
new shows this 2020.
yes glibney went on some sort of anime
original direction towards the end
leaving everyone confused while season 2
is nowhere in sight but why is it here
why is it in my top 10 list
because after everything else the show
does well and hits the right beats for
me having just come off enjoying
darwin's
game earlier this season i was simply in
the mood for more edgy death game
shenanigans while the former i loved
especially with the ensemble concept and
the character designs i won't deny that
it would seem a bit generic for it to
truly stand out what isn't generic in
terms of setup and characters
is glipenir i praised pine jam for
powering through the uncertainties of
the spring 2020 season and giving us an
a
plus product in terms of animation and
fights but glyphonet also finds its
strength in something else
it's characters its characters are an
underrated aspect of the show and you
can't really quantify chemistry but the
main duo of shuichi and claire as well
as the antagonist elena just works so
well together the side characters are no
slouch either
being interesting in their own ways and
showing varying degrees of agency
a weird bizarro ending wouldn't
completely pull a good show down
and glibney remains one of my favorites
of this year
as we reach the halfway mark of this
list let me ask you a question
how many of these shows can you watch
legally it sure must be a pain to go to
crunchyroll or funimation then run into
the dreaded region lock message
thus it's with great joy that i bring to
you a cheap and easy solution to that
expressvpn to the rescue with
expressvpn's amazing
service you can connect to so many
different proxy servers from all over
the world
that way you can access anime just like
the more privileged people in the world
for its cheap subscription price you get
some top-notch quality service
and the fastest speeds available for any
vpn software in town once you boot the
program up just pick your server and
connect
it really is as simple as that now
movies like your name and spirited away
are just a click away
so say goodbye to those guilt-ridden
days where you had to overcome
regional locks through dubious means
let's just put it like that
here let me help you out by giving you
three months free and all you have to do
is click the link below or
just go to expressvpn.com vinnie tube
say goodbye to all those problems with
some quick clicks and start enjoying the
internet
to the fullest
[Music]
yes i intentionally put two dark series
next to each other so next we take a
look at
doro hidaro that's a handful of a title
yes and no dorothy dora isn't an
edgy death game anime glyph name may be
dark and edgy but i still find it to
know when to reel itself
in and step back before letting you see
that at its very core it's still a boy
mean skill series but with morally
ambiguous characters
but that's not the case for doro hidaro
dorido relishes in the violence
the black comedy and that sort of stuff
no wonder it didn't become a mainstream
title at the start of the year
then again it's probably a saving grace
because if it did indeed become a
mainstream title we'd be seeing all
those controversies online i mean it's
the same season as inter-species
reviewers and i don't think that
anything that season could top the
funimation fiasco with that show but can
you imagine a world with a mainstream
doro hiduro with a series of
controversies of its own airing
alongside
inter-species reviewers however don't
let all the talk of the violence and
controversial elements distract you from
the fact that dora hidara is quite
honestly a
very well made adaptation i mean the cgi
may be jarring but i truly felt that the
anime captured a lot of things that made
the manga such a hit
the setting and the atmosphere is there
and the characters are just amazing
which is a good thing because at its
core doro hiduro is a character-driven
show it's truly worthy of a watch and
while i don't see a sequel coming
anytime soon i still recommend it to
anyone who enjoys the darker side of
anime
spring 2020 saw the start of the korean
wave in anime with tower of god leading
the charge
there's no question that when pioneering
a new thing you put your best foot
forward and tried to make an impact off
the bat so of course when the idea of
webtoons being adapted into anime became
a thing the immediate candidate was
probably the biggest webtoon out there
tower of god the result was actually
pretty good i think that a number of
people were disappointed because it's
the tower of god and that they had high
hopes after being so enamored with the
webtoon but as someone who came in and
started watching the show
knowing the source materials content i
think that the series does well enough
for itself it's a dialogue heavy
adventure series featuring some
intriguing characters and a vivid world
for us to explore it also features a
unique art style that would or wouldn't
be a big pull for fans of webtoons the
unfortunate part is that what we saw of
tower of god is basically just the
prologue the anime just ended there
without a season two in sight
come on it's like ending hunter hunter
right when the hunter exams end
all that being said for me tower of god
is among the best webtoon adaptations
the third best animate of 2020 well it's
a toss up for me for second and third
place
but for now i'll give it to it invaded
i've always been quite high on
psychological anime so it wasn't any
surprise that i watched it invaded being
such a fan of psychology myself
i think that it's one of the great
topics that can be discussed in so many
ways through different forms of media
heck i liked it invaded so much that i
put it as my top anime at the start of
the year but
personal biases aside i do think that it
invaded is legitimately a great show
that can appeal to a wide range of anime
fans
it's just a solid mystery anime after
all in a way it really reminds me of an
alternative psycho pass but with a more
scientific focus instead of a more
moralistic one it's a thriller that
keeps you wanting more and it's got no
shortage of action and its own special
identity
it's the end of the year and i still
think that it's a grossly
under-appreciated anime
seeing as how big psycho pass has become
i feel a bit bad that it invaded never
really got to that point
maybe it's just a change in the times
after all many things can change in a
decade maybe it's because the winter
2020 has the unfortunate reputation
of being a weak season either way i
strongly recommend watching this show to
anyone looking for a good
suspenseful watch
second place goes to jujutsu kaizen with
all the bars that's taken over the
internet over this show for the past few
weeks how could it not be near the top
of the list
it's really amazing because at first
glance jiu-jitsu kaizen may seem like a
show filling everyone's annual quota of
shonen jump series
featuring supernatural powers demons and
exorcists and whatever equivalents to
those a show may have
last year it was demon slayer a few
years before that it was black clover
however jiu jitsu kaizen just does so
many things right as far as its target
market is concerned for a show like this
i think that the most important keys are
simply having a good hook
a decent and likeable cast some twists
and turns regarding certain characters
and great fights that showcase the
powers that the creator came up with
let's just say the jiu jitsu kaizen
passes
everything with flying colours it's yet
to get a demon slayer episode 19 moment
but the recent one featuring one of its
most popular characters came pretty damn
close with how it blew up the internet
however for all the excitement
surrounding it only finds its way to
number two on my list
it's not that i don't buy the hype or
anything i mean i love it and i really
like how there's this big new thing that
everyone's talking about again
the likes that i've not seen since demon
slayer however there's just
one new anime that i think i like better
what is the show that i consider to be
the best of 2020 you ask
great pretender of course
[Music]
don't worry this surprised me even when
i first looked up the series i didn't
expect to find myself becoming such a
big fan of great pretender
but i did in the end i ended up being so
entertained following con artists and
their mishaps all over the world
is it because of the unique premise or
is it because it looked like some kind
of spiritual successor to things i
enjoyed like boccano or better call saul
probably a mixture of both i think
actually great pretender is a breath of
fresh air that would look like a western
tv series had it not been done in an
anime format
saying that it's unique isn't enough and
it's a completely different direction
from what we've all come to expect from
the media now i'm not part of the camp
where unique
automatically equals good and i
personally love my anime tropes
but come on credit where credit's due
pretty much everything in great
pretender is
amazing the visuals are stunning the
plot progresses at a great pace
and it manages to keep me entertained
all the way to the very end
i'm sure that it'll do the job for you
too it's a super fun show so check it
out i just find it unfortunate that
great pretender
never really became a big deal it's just
a fun and artistic show full of soul and
promise
do i blame netflix jail for this well
partly but i still consider it the top
pick for the best new title in 2020 and
i don't see my opinion changing anytime
soon so what does your top 10 list look
like i'd love to know so let's chat a
bit about it in the comments section as
we look forward to 2021 we'll always
remember
2020 to be an eventful year both in
expected and
unexpected ways whether the momentum
from 2020 will carry on to make an even
better 2021 is yet to be seen but i've
always been a believer in the idea that
anime just keeps getting better
instead of the best ones being in the
good old days so i've got a positive
outlook for this statement
as usual i encourage you to like and
share the video with your friends who
knows maybe they can even like it and
subscribe to the channel and join the
family
don't forget to check out our sponsors
of this video expressvpn
bypass all those pesky region locks and
even browse sites not available in your
region
with the ever trustee expressvpn now
let's keep our spirits up and march to a
hopefully better 2021 together
see ya
[Music]
you